on se dit où là c'est ce sont des
montants très significatifs je confirme
que ce sont des montants très
significatifs mais les montants qui ont
été investis et que les profits
d'aujourd'hui qu'on pense sont très
significatifs aussi pour le gouvernement
les critères de calcul de la rentabilité
retenue lors de la privatisation n'était
pas bon à reconnu Bruno Le Maire le
ministre de l'Économie avance
aujourd'hui deux possibilités réduire de
quelques années la durée de ces
concessions mais également une clause de
révision de ces contrats ces deux
principes non de sens car deux
conditions la première c'est que la
durée des concessions soient plus courte
certaines concessions ont jusqu'à 75 ans
c'est durées qui sont beaucoup trop
longues et la deuxième condition c'est
le maintien pour l'état de la capacité
de modifier directement le tarif des
péages les autres recommandations du
rapport de l'Inspection générale des
finances à savoir une baisse de 60% du
prix des péages ou une taxe de 63% des
prof non selon toute vraisemblance
aucune chance d'aboutir juridiquement on
en débat tout de suite avec Vincent
Delahaye bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénateur Union centriste de
l'Essonne et vice-prés en duel ancien
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
justement sur ces concessions
autoroutières qui avaient été mené en
2020 à Martine orange bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste à Mediapart et vous avez
enquêté depuis plusieurs années sur les
concessions d'autoroute sur les sociétés
l'autoroute Olivier Babeau bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi professeur
université de Bordeaux président de
l'Institut sapiens et puis je signale
que vous publiez ça n'est pas notre
thème mais je signale votre eu la
tyrannie du divertissement qui est aux
éditions bûcher Chastel Émilie zapalski
évidemment est resté à mes côtés Vincent
delay je commence avec vous parce que je
l'ai dit vous étiez rapporteur de cette
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur les
concessions autoroutières 2020 qu'est-ce
que vous aviez découvert qu'est-ce qui
était le plus frappant pour vous le plus
frappant c'est qu'il y avait un péché
originel dans ses concessions
autoroutières c'est que les contrats
avaient été conclus en fait entre l'État
et problème puisque c'était des sociétés
d'économie mixtes qui qui concluaient
avec l'État donc il l'avait fait plutôt
pour la forme et qu'au moment de la
privatisation d'ouverture privée à la
fois par Jospin en 2002 et ensuite par
2000 pas en 2006 plus largement en fait
c'est contrats n'ont pas été modifiées
donc on avait des contrats de longue
durée avec son sans aucune clause de
revoyure et finalement avec assez peu de
contrôle de la part du Conseil dent et
possibilité de contrôle donc aujourd'hui
les sociétés d'autoroute sont assises
sur ces contrats elle considère que si
on touche la moindre virgule du contrat
on touche à l'équilibre du contrat c'est
comme une aberration et on a on a peu de
moyens si on montre pas une grande
fermeté on a peu de moyens de d'obtenir
des évolutions puisque en fait elles
sont assises sur une rentabilité énorme
quand elle vous disent et quand le
patron de Vinci que convient d'entendre
dit en audition tranquillement ah ben
vous savez les concessions c'est des
choses très longues et au début on fait
des pertes après on rattrape en réalité
ils ont jamais fait de perte si vous
prenez tout le résultat nous on a repris
toute la séquence de résultat il y a
jamais eu de perte et puis pardonateur
puis il y a eu ce plan de relance
autorité qui a été signé 2015-2016 vous
dites que les sociétés autoroutières
elles ont atteint leurs objectifs de
rentabilité et que donc l'État pourrait
la des la mi-juillet je crois c'est pour
Vinci c'est ça la société parce que vous
avez pas vous avez trois groupes vous
avez Vinci Eiffage et un groupe espagnol
aptiste à bertis c'est le nord de la
France et la Normandie et eux ils auront
atteint le 8% de rentabilité en fait les
actionnaires quand ils ont investi en
2006 quand ça a été ouvert totalement
privé ils sont fixés des objectifs de
rentabilité donc pour nous c'est ce que
moi j'appelle l'équilibre du contrat
l'équipe du contrat c'est de se dire ben
voilà on investit tant d'argent 16
milliards à l'époque et on se dit bah on
va avoir 8% de rentabilité et oui pour
son rentabilité c'est ce que Vinci aura
atteint fin 2023 et ils ont des contrats
qui durent jusqu'en 2036 donc faudrait
sortir du contrat c'est ça moi je trouve
que c'est possible c'est possible dans
les concessions dont le service public
quand vous avez des concessions d'eau ou
de d'ordures ménagères si la société
gagne moins que ce qu'elle avait prévu
et même si elle perd de l'argent elle
peut dénoncer le contrat donc moi je dis
parallélisme des formes je vois pas
pourquoi le Conseil peut pas dire on a
dépassé évidemment un peu plus tard dans
ce débat Martine orange je le disais
dans longtemps sur les concessions de
route si je vois on va remonter un peu
plus loin dans le temps mais si je parle
de 2015 ce plan de relance autoroutier
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dedans qui le signe
qui le signe c'est Emmanuel Macron en
tant que ministre de l'Économie et
Ségolène Royal en tant que ministre de
la transition écologique ou de
l'environnement je me souviens plus
exactement son titre et donc à partir de
ce moment-là ce plan il a été
négocié
à la suite de l'échec des Comores parce
qu'on oublie on oublie ça et donc dès
qu'on ouvre c'est-à-dire le moment où il
était question de mettre
sur les portiques non de mettre un péage
sur le
transporter l'autoroute à ce moment-là
il y avait une augmentation de tarif qui
était prévue en février de 2015 et Golan
Royal dit non on arrête cette on arrête
on bloque cette cette augmentation de
tarif et là dessus il y a une une
bagarre qui qui intervient entre entre
les concessionnaires et l'État
il faut savoir aussi comme un moment il
y avait quand même une commission qui
était à l'Assemblée nationale justement
sur les autoroutes et qui avait un
projet de renationalisation des
autoroutes et qui était signé par 152
députés déjà qui demandaient et or ce
bocage le blocage des tarifs plus
les problèmes juridiques qui est qui a
bloquer toute l'initiative de de de ces
députés qui et ces Bercy qui a repris
qui a repris ce contrat et négocier ce
contrat contre un négocié par deux
personnes que vous connaissez bien
Alexis colère est aujourd'hui secrétaire
général de l'Élysée Elisabeth borne qui
était à l'époque directrice de cabinet
de Ségolène Royal Olivier Babou est-ce
que l'État a mal négocié ça peut arriver
ces contrats alors oui c'est possible
que on n'est pas eu à l'époque
totalement l'expertise qu'il fallait
pour des contrats qui sont extrêmement
compliqués c'est vrai aussi que quand on
fait de ces contrats comme ça on est
obligé de faire des hypothèses qui se
révèlent pas les bonnes par exemple
celle sur les taux d'intérêt on était
obligé de supposer les taux d'intérêt
qui étaient relativement haut en fait
ils ont été très débats ce qui fait que
les sociétés ont pu s'endetter à un coût
bien moindre et donc ce qui fait
mathématiquement augmenter la la
rentabilité il y a plein d'aléas
théoriquement effectivement
effectivement il y a un risque qui est
un petit peu réparti si ils avaient
perdu massivement de l'argent je pense
que l'État aurait probablement dû dû à
Dieu intervenir c'est c'est assez
possible donc il y a cette incertitude
là ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est à la
fin du marché qu'on compte les bouses
comme on dit à la campagne il faut
regarder il faut faire la lumière sur
l'intégralité des investissements et la
rentabilité à ma connaissance très
souvent quand on augmente les la durée
c'est parce que en fait c'est un un
donnant donnant le gouvernement demande
des nouveaux tronçons de nouveaux
investissements qui étaient pas prévus
et donc il y a une négociation qui est
faite en permanence parce que c'est ce
qui est passé par nos interrompre en
2015 il y a une prolongation une
prorogation c'est ça en général c'est la
conséquence de nouveaux tronçons de
nouveaux investissements qui n'étaient
pas prévus voilà ce qui est certain
c'est que des causes de revoyure il en
fallait beaucoup plus et il en faut
beaucoup plus parce qu'il faut que en
permanence ça puisse être évidemment
suivi mais il faut que les Français
comprennent bien le problème de la
concession qui est un super modèle
extraordinaire depuis du 14 depuis le
canal du midi un truc génial on est on
s'est dit on n'a pas l'argent l'état pas
envie de mettre l'argent on va laisser
l'argent laisser les investissements à
une sorte de commerce en privé qui va
créer les infrastructures les utiliser
ce pays dans les conditions qu'il faut
qu'il faut évidemment déterminer et puis
à la fin ils nous rend le tout c'est à
dire ça ce truc reste public si on
contrôle bien évidemment si on sait si
la rentabilité est fixée de façon à ce
que évidemment l'ensemble des gens est
pas la pression de payer mais le
problème c'est que la question c'est
parce que c'est gratuit ou payant
attention parce que les Français peuvent
avoir l'impression que si ça ne
nationaliser une paieront pas non c'est
ce que c'est l'usagé ou le contribuable
il n'est pas tout à fait certain que ça
soit moins cher collectivement si c'est
nationalisé parce que il y a un
savoir-faire
je pense que ça donne un peu une leçon
aussi sur l'état négociateur je pense
que en effet les concessions c'est
probablement une très bonne solution et
on comprend bien que l'État peut pas
tout faire et qu'il délègue à des
entreprises privées certains de ses
services certaines de ses actions mais
ça se complique et c'est vrai que les
entreprises en face quand on a Vinci ou
Eiffage avec des services juridiques
avec enfin on voit sur les chantiers ce
qu'ils font dans le domaine du BTP ou
quoi c'est c'est des armées entières
est-ce que l'État est suffisamment armé
pour prévoir ces contrats à la base pour
les négociés ensuite pour sortir de là
sans payer 40 milliards si on veut
renationaliser un cabinet de conseils
non mais on sent que il y a besoin dans
cet état de rénover un petit peu
peut-être les matières et de et d'avoir
un volet un petit peu plus vite tout le
temps parce que là on a voulu aller
beaucoup trop vite et puis avec des
contrats et aujourd'hui on a des
contractions qui sont beaucoup mieux
ficelés quand même depuis 2015 il y a eu
des progrès considérables sur les
contrats alors même si Bruno Le Maire
disait tout à l'heure il y en a qui sont
75 ans mais en fait la durée des
contrats dépend de la rentabilité de du
tronçon auquel on s'adresse parce que si
le tronçon est pas vraiment rentable et
qu'il y a quand même des investissements
assez important il faut forcément que la
durée soit assez longue et plus la durée
longue plus il faut de clauses de
revoyure de façon c'est que les revoyons
elles sont indispensables c'est c'est un
moment de discussion et d'échanges et on
remet les choses à plat là en fait ça
n'a jamais été fait alors si on parle de
rentabilité quel quelques chiffres
donnés par l'auto autorité de régulation
des transports qui datent de ce mois de
janvier sur les bénéfices des sociétés
concessionnaires on affiche près de 4
milliards d'euros en 2021 c'est plus 47
% par rapport à 2020 alors 2020 c'était
une année évidemment particulière année
de covid de confinement donc il y avait
eu des chiffres beaucoup moins
importants pour ces sociétés mais même
si on revient à l'année de référence qui
est souvent 2019 dans le business plus
11% par rapport à 2019 je reprends la
démonstration faisait tout à l'heure
Vincent Nola et sur et on va prendre
l'exemple de Vinci qui est le plus le
plus proche en temps si la concession
telle que c'est prévu continue pour
Vinci on va arriver à quel niveau de
rentabilité ou de surprofit ces
termes-là il faut il faut que l'on
s'entende bien sur ce qu'est la
rentabilité et parce que pour l'instant
on sait pas vraiment entendu et personne
veut se mettre autour de la table
gouvernement pas envie de se mettre
autour à table et société d'autoroute
non plus personne finalement se met
autour de la table pour nous nous on a
essayé de faire on a pris des risques
au niveau du Sénat on a dit voilà pour
nous la rentabilité c'est la rentabilité
actionnaire c'est-à-dire klaxonaire
rapporte 16 milliards et puis on regarde
ce qui est ce qu'il en retire et bien
sûr que c'est à la fin des contrats
qu'on détermine exactement mais on peut
faire des prévisions c'est-à-dire que
moi en tant que rapporteur j'ai vu des
prévisions des sociétés d'autoroute sauf
que à chaque fois qu'il me donnait des
chiffres il y avait c'était couvert par
secret des affaires parce qu'il y a un
secret des affaires jusqu'en 2036 vous
voyez les trucs en 2036 mais il y a
quand même un secret des affaires donc
on peut pas publier ces chiffres donc
moi j'ai publié mes propres chiffres
j'ai dit moi je veux publier des
chiffres donc j'ai publié mes propres
chiffres et bien sûr mes propres
chiffres sont assez proches des leurs
c'est pas les leurs mais j'ai pris des
hypothèses qui font que que c'est c'est
pas loin d'être le donc avec avec notre
travail on peut calculer la rentabilité
sur la durée du contrat avec bien sûr
des chiffres révisionnels qui sont
soumis à quelques aléases forcément ou
donc à partir de 2024 si ça continue
pour ainsi je repose la question
différemment c'est quoi c'est des
milliards en plus chaque année c'est à
dire que d'ici la des contrats c'est à
dire que pour ainsi c'est 2036 pour
effacer 2034 pour avertir ces 2031 2031
à berthys moi pour moi c'est presque pas
un problème puisque ils auront atteint
leur 8% en 2031 d'accord
donc moi je parle plutôt des deux autres
et deux autres il faut savoir qu'à
partir de 2023 2024 donc Vinci 2023 et
phase 2024 là ils ont atteint les 8 % et
au-delà ils vont aller jusqu'à 12%.
alors nous on avait calculé 11 11 30 11
40 l'inspection générale des finances
qu'a validé notre notre calcul notre
méthodologie de calcul de la rentabilité
actionnaire eux ils arrivent à 12% donc
ça veut dire que ils auront 50% de plus
de rentabilité que ce qui était attendu
à l'origine et ça ça fait si on traduit
en milliard ça fait entre 30 et 35
milliards à discuter merci d'avoir
regardé pour moi c'est cet enjeu de
discussion d'accord on écoute la réponse
du du président de Vinci autorout on l'a
vu dans le sujet mais c'est intéressant
effectivement il était auditionné au CRM
au Sénat le 29 mars pierre Coppet sur
cette formation j'ai bien compris que il
a regardé quelques-unes secrets des
affaires sur cette question de la
rentabilité
le débat sur la rentabilité des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute ne repose
des reposent de moins en moins sur des
considérations
objectifs et que on est bien souvent
dans des débordements passionnels et
j'en appelle simplement au fait que une
concession c'est un contrat dans lequel
il y a des obligations et des
compensations avec un modèle dans lequel
il y a des hypothèses que
l'ensemble de ces éléments sont suivis à
la fois par le ministère des Transports
le Conseil d'État et l'Autorité de
régulation des transports et que si vous
interrogez l'ensemble de ces
institutions elle considère que nous
sommes tout à fait dans le cadre de ce
qui a été prévu dans le dans le contrat
les conditions du contrat sont
respectées un grosso modo voilà ce que
dit le patron de Vinci Autoroutes
Martine orange est-ce que c'est vrai
tiens par exemple sur on vous donne
trois ans de plus à condition que vous
fassiez les travaux supplémentaires déjà
comme je suis le signaler il y a déjà le
problème avec le secret des affaires et
l'opacité qui entoure ses contrats
sachant quand même qu'il faut rappeler
que ils ont repris des autoroutes et des
concessions ou l'essentiel était
construit c'était c'était
des ouvrages qui étaient achevés je veux
dire que shiroute
c'est l'État qui l'a construit le les
autoroutes de Normandie c'est l'État qui
l'a construit donc ce sont des ouvrages
qui sont déjà construits et amorti
largement
de construire des des nouvelles
autoroutes quand même pour les nouveaux
pour les nouveaux tronçons c'est
différent mais l'essentiel pour qui pour
ce qui concerne ce Vinci et Fage et
avertisse ce sont des ce sont déjà des
ouvrages qui sont construits depuis
longtemps donc là le problème de
rentabilité déjà il est pas du tout le
même que si vous prenez que si vous
prenez pari Le Havre ou Paris le Rouen
ou
Aix-en-Provence le gap qui
juridique et donc financier pour l'État
ce qui est certain c'est que je suis pas
juriste et spécial mais c'est que ça se
réglera devant les tribunaux et les
tribunaux sont pouvoirs qui est
indépendant et donc on ne sait pas ce
qu'ils vont juger sur sur le sur cette
affaire car la réalité c'est quand il y
a un contrat théoriquement il oblige
mutuellement quand on a signé un mauvais
contrat et il arrive qu'on se mord les
doigts malheureusement alors est-ce que
la puissance publique peut avoir la
possibilité
d'idées dans quelles conditions c'est ce
que la justice dira ce qui est certain
c'est qu'on n'est pas tout à fait sûr de
la fin des courses et de comment ça va
se passer c'est là qu'un aléa qui qui
est un peu gênant ce qu'il faut dire
c'est qu'on fait rien ah ben non non si
on fait quelque chose si on fait
la concession et le contentieux il faut
dire sur cette affaire que c'est quand
même l'illustration malheureusement d'un
état impliqué mieux qui parle l'odeur
des milliards à lécher à signer tout de
suite parce que tellement c'était
formidable de toucher ton milliards on y
reviendra sur la privatisation
judiciaire moi je pense je pense que le
fait que l'État dise oui on peut
dénoncer je pense que ça va obliger les
sociétés d'autoroute à venir autour de
la table et à un moment donné il faut
les obliger à venir autour de la table
aujourd'hui le rapport de force il est
en leur faveur et quand il y a un
rapport de force en faveur de d'un camp
il faut pouvoir l'inverser et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement est pas
seulement ce gouvernement aussi mais les
précédents n'ont pas eu assez de volonté
pour inverser ce rapport de force je
pense que le Conseil dent est la
puissance publique est suffisamment
forte normalement pour pouvoir inverser
un peu ce rapport de force et c'est ce
qu'il faut arriver à faire là maintenant
et on est dans ce et c'est bien d'en
parler parce que je vous remercie d'en
parler aujourd'hui il y a quand même pas
mal de médias qui sont qui sont saisis
et c'est bien parce que c'est un sujet
on peut pas laisser les choses se faire
si on écoute effectivement les
concessionnaires ils vont vous dire ah
bah on attend la fin on attend la fin
des courses et on verra bien ce qui se
fera passer mais ça sera trop tard il y
a moyen il y a levier parce que le
levier c'est la preuve c'est la
prolongation puisque bon l'idée n'est
comme priori on peut en discuter mais
pas de nationalisation ça veut dire
prolongation mais à ce moment-là dans
quel dans quelles conditions donc le
gouvernement a la possibilité de dire
bon on peut peut-être s'arranger tout de
suite avant que ça soit plus dur plus
tard amour rapidement
2015 il y a quand même une clause qui
prévoit qui prévoit que un
raccourcissement de délai de concession
en cas de sur profit et donc cette cette
clause existe donc elle peut tout à fait
être actionnée et c'est pas et c'est pas
par hasard que l'Inspection générale des
finances a évoqué cette possibilité
puisqu'elle était écrite dans le contrat
et vous dites qu'on y est dans cette
dans ce cas de figure des super bons
films alors justement il y a ce mot qui
revient Émilie dans notre débat ici et
puis depuis plusieurs semaines en France
peut-être depuis que il y a eu cette
décision d'augmentation des tarifs
c'était début février augmentation de
4,75% en moyenne des tarifs d'autoroute
ça a remis un coup de projecteur sur ces
concessions autoroutières et sur les
profits que les sociétés faisaient oui
parce que c'est un peu chasser les super
profits reviennent au galop cette
séquence donc en effet sur les
autoroutes elle nous ramène à ce sujet
et encore une fois notre ministre de
l'Économie particulièrement Bruno Le
Maire qui d'ailleurs était dans
l'affaire en 2006 ne veut pas en
entendre parler des super profits à
peine ils consent que les calculs de
rentabilité on la signalé les critères
qui avaient été choisis au moment de la
vente des autoroutes en 2006 et puis de
la renégociation n'était pas les bons et
qu'il faudrait réduire de quelques
années la durée des concessions mais
c'est pas la première fois finalement
que le ministre de l'Économie botte en
touche quand on prononce devant lui ce
mot magique on l'écoute c'était lors de
l'université d'été du Medef fin août
vous avez bien sûr entendu parler de
cette polémique aussi sur les super
profits non
n'étiez pas là cet été alors non mais je
ne sais pas ce que c'est qu'un super
profit
donc non je n'ai pas entendu je sais que
les entreprises doivent être profitables
c'est tout ce que je sais
alors donc Bruno Le Maire ne s'est pas
ce que c'est que les super-profis
pourtant au moment même les grandes
entreprises françaises annoncées des
dividendes records on était sur plus de
44 milliards d'euros versés pour le
deuxième trimestre 2022 donc des sommes
quand même assez conséquentes et ça
discutait beaucoup à l'Assemblée
nationale autour de ça au point que la
première ministre elle-même Elisabeth
borne avait indiqué c'était dans Le
Parisien à la même période ne pas fermer
la porte à une taxe sur les super
profits elle-même comme un écho demande
qui était réitérer de l'opposition
durant les discussions sur le projet de
loi de finance pour 2023 côté nupes
évidemment mais aussi du côté des alliés
du gouvernement je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez il y avait eu un amendement qui
avait été déposé par le modem sur le
sujet donc des super profits et quelques
mois auparavant le président de la
République avait lui-même réagi à ce
sujet c'était en juin 2022 lors du
sommet du G7 en Allemagne on l'écoute
certains producteurs et beaucoup de
spéculateurs
qui font beaucoup d'argent sur le
contexte géopolitique est-ce que ça peut
durer non nous avons des gens qui ont
spéculé sur la guerre et aujourd'hui
vous avez des gens qui font beaucoup
d'argent sur la guerre
on appelle ça des profiteurs de guerre
une charge donc brutale sur ses
profiteurs de guerre mais qui selon
Emmanuel Macron devait se régler au
niveau européen et la rhétorique est une
fois de plus délicatement choisir
c'est pas une taxe sur les super profit
on est sur une contribution
exceptionnelle qui est demandé aux
énergéticiens pourquoi une telle
attention alors il s'agit pour le
ministre de l'économie comme pour le
président de pas ouvrir la boîte de
Pandore parce que finalement si on taxe
les super profits des énergéticiens on
va pouvoir faire la même chose sur la
grande distribution des assureurs les
banques etc en gros toutes les
entreprises qui feraient des profits
supplémentaires excédentaires est-ce
qu'on considère comme raisonnable et
globalement c'est tout l'inverse du
choix du gouvernement qui est assez
libéral c'est à dire alléger les
entreprises des taxes superflues entre
avant leur croissance on le voit même
avec les impôts de production qui ont
été allégées
actuelle des autoroutes montrent que le
sujet n'est pas clos et que on va en
reparler il faudra peut-être à terme
penser à aller plus loin et surtout
dépasser cette guerre idéologique super
profit pas super profit pour adopter
peut-être une approche plus pragmatique
on en parlait pourquoi l'État ne
profiterait pas des super profits
réalisés par des sociétés qui exploitent
tout simplement ses infrastructures
comme vous le rappeliez tout à l'heure
votre avis là-dessus alors c'est un
sujet intéressant et compliqué
effectivement le terme ne super profit
est gênant parce que parce qu'il y a pas
de définition claire et donc la façon
dont ce moment-là on va partir du moment
où on l'accepte c'est un peu comme turbo
ultra néolibéralisme c'est que ça veut
pas dire grand chose en fait on peut le
dire ça peut utiliser être utilisé dans
le débat public mais c'est pas très
actionnable économiquement le terme de
super profit physiquement il y a des
profits alors effectivement en économie
on connaît le terme de rente par exemple
théoriquement le profit doit être la
contrepartie d'une prise de risque par
exemple donc en fait on pourrait dire
qu'il y a des profits qui sont indus qui
sont peut-être excessifs en tout cas
dans le cas des énergies
énergéticiens pardon évidemment une
condition un peu difficile c'est assez
différent et ça peut être assez assez
compréhensible il faut dire que c'est
déjà fiscalisé je veux dire les profils
ne sont pas pas fiscaux ils sont pas
fiscalisés d'ailleurs il y a je crois
qu'il y a 40% du prix du péage que vous
payez qui sont à ma connaissance c'est
des impôts qui sont versés c'est-à-dire
que l'État ils touchent déjà il touche à
proportion des profits qui sont
supérieurs la question c'est ce qu'on
doit plus fiscaliser les profits qui
sont au-delà donc est-ce qu'on fait une
forme de progressivité dans dans la
taxation sur les la taxi sur les
entreprises il faut dire que même s'il y
a eu de la baisse sur les impôts de
productions on est quand même partie les
entreprises françaises sont parmi les
plus fiscalisés du monde quand même donc
voilà on peut parler de productivité et
de pardon de compétitivité il y a un
moment donné si on veut que les
entreprises réussissent et embauche il
faut peut-être qu'elle soit Vincent
parce que c'est vrai que au Sénat
l'Union centriste vous l'avez pas dit
mais on avait déposé un amendement nous
sur une contribution exceptionnelle
c'est moi qui a trouvé le terme je suis
content que ça a été reprise par
ailleurs et j'avais défini ce qui me
semblait être des profils n'ont pas des
super profits mais en fait des profits
un peu exceptionnels dans une période de
crise il faut s'en souvenir quand même
où on a lâché les milliards dans tous
les sens donc on y allait on ne
soutenait tout le monde on soutenait les
entreprises on soutenait les
particuliers on est allé dans tous les
sens donc on a lâché tout très bien donc
dans cette période-là moi il me semblait
pas moi je suis pas fana des des apôtres
parce qu'il y a pas des entreprises qui
pètent trop d'impôts les particuliers
aussi en France on a une dépense
publique qui est très importante donc
forcément en face on essaie d'avoir un
niveau d'impôt qui est pas suffisant
parce qu'on a difficile de 160 milliards
je vous le rappelle donc c'est ça veut
dire que les niveaux des impôts est pas
suffisant par rapport à nos dépenses et
on va encore nous annoncer 413 milliards
de plans pour la défense moi je je je
n'ai pas vu tout à l'heure c'est vrai
que moi je trouve ça assez pharaon on
s'endette sur les générations futures
probablement pour vous dire nous nous
comment on avait défini moi j'avais dit
dans la période de 2020 2021 les
sociétés qui font des profits qui sont
supérieurs à 20% de ce qu'elle faisait
les trois années précédentes à la
moyenne des trois années précédentes on
connaît 2019-2018 2017 des années normal
et on se disait quand on est au-delà de
20% à ce moment-là on prend une partie
on prend une partie on prend pas la
totalité de ce qui excède non on en
prend une partie pour contribuer en fait
à l'effort collectif et moi je trouve ça
je trouvais ça normal je trouve toujours
ça normal je trouve pas et je suis pas
pour que ça soit durable je dis que
c'est vraiment une contribution
exceptionnelle sur ces années-là je
trouvais pas aberrant que ces grandes
sociétés qui tant mieux font des profits
on est content d'avoir soucis qui font
des profits mais on est content aussi
qu'elle participe à l'effort collectif
Martin orange oui non mais moi je
voulais revenir sur le terme de super
profil nous sommes pas dans un cas de
super profit nous sommes dans un cadre
pour les autoroutes pour les autoroutes
et dans les autoroutes je veux dire on
va revenir à un terme de définition
économique assez simple nous sommes en
plein dans une situation de monopole
physique naturelle en économie à partir
de ce moment là il y a deux choses ou le
mono on sait que tout monopole physique
très une rente à partir de ce moment là
où c'est l'État qui la prend ce faisait
avant avec les autoroutes ce qui
permettait de financer et le
développement du ferroviaire et le
développement des routes ou c'est où
on décide de le de le confier au privé
et à partir de ce moment-là avec des
autorités de régulation et avec du avec
un contrôle une régulation extrêmement
forte il y a d'autres pays où ça existe
notamment en Grande-Bretagne au moins
ils ont été jusqu'à la logique du show
et je peux vous assurer que les
autorités de régulation
britanniques sont des régulations
sérieuses avec des pénalités sérieuses
etc nous avons des des autorités de
régulation inexistantes en France ce qui
fait qu'il perd ça permet de de
à la rente de prospérer nous sommes en
devant un oligopole privé qui
identique
et à partir de ce moment là
ça suppose et je vais vous citer juste
un exemple quand elles ont pris quand
elles ont pris les sociétés la première
chose qu'elles elles ont décapitalisé
ces sociétés
on remplaçant le capital par des
emprunts puisque les emprunts sont à
partir de ce moment-là déductibles de
l'impôt sur les sociétés et donc vous
faites apparaître mécaniquement une
moindre rentabilité de la société pour
payer mon impôts pour payer moins
d'impôts et là vous remontez évidemment
à l'époque de la privatisation on va en
parler tout de suite grâce à Quentin
calmé puisque dans ce feuilleton des
concessions autoroutières rebonsoir
Quentin il y a évidemment cette étape
ultra importante 2005-2006 avec
notamment Dominique de Villepin voilà on
le disait sous Jospin le capital des
autoroutes avait été ouvert au privé
mais toujours avec un état qui était
majoritaire c'est effectivement en 2005
que Dominique de Villepin et son
ministre des Finances Thierry Breton
prennent la décision de franchir le pas
l'état vend ses participations dans les
sociétés aux concessionnaires pour
14,8 milliards d'euros une décision qui
interroge à l'époque à droite exemple
Gilles Carrez à l'époque rapporteur UMP
du budget dira en 2019 c'est un bijou de
famille un élément du patrimoine qu'il
ne fallait pas brader alors en 2020 au
Sénat la commission d'enquête avait reçu
Dominique de Villepin pour refaire un
peu le feuilleton à l'époque où vous
étiez rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête et bien Dominique depain se
défendra de tout erreur avec au passage
une petite mise au point à l'écoute nous
n'avons pas décidé la privatisation des
autoroutes les autoroutes françaises
font partie du domaine public
contrairement à ce que l'on peut parfois
lire ou entendre l'état on est toujours
le propriétaire à la fin du contrat de
concession nous autoroutes ne
disparaîtront pas et demeureront la
propriété des Français à la fin des
contrats soit dans les conditions de
2005 à compter de 2028 l'état récupérera
une infrastructure en très bon état
améliorée sur la base des travaux de
rénovation et d'aménagement imposés par
les cahiers des charges de l'État en
gouvernement n'a pas bradé les bijoux de
famille pas plus qu'il n'a tué
bien au contraire on le voit un pas de
mai à coule pas sur les éléments dans
les contrats signal à l'époque mais un
petit aveu qu'il a dit aussi il était
alors pieds et points liés par l'Europe
dit-il contraint de se conformer je cite
aux exigences de la Commission
européenne qui était favorable à
l'ouverture à la concurrence c'est une
citation alors il y a une deuxième étape
que l'on va rappeler là on est en 2014
des alertes qui fusent dans tous les
sens sur la sur rentabilité on y revient
des sociétés d'autoroute voilà c'est la
deuxième étape aussi inquiéter par vos
invités depuis le début effectivement
plusieurs instances à ce moment-là elle
tire la sonnette d'alarme l'Autorité de
la concurrence la Cour des comptes même
le Sénat à l'époque et l'Assemblée
nationale qui parle de cette rentabilité
exceptionnelle une ministre mais les
pieds dans le plat Ségolène Royal elle
tente d'instaurer un bras de fer décide
même de geler les tarifs des péages
Ségolène Royal qui racontera des années
plus tard à nouveau en 2020 et que les
sociétés d'autoroute refusaient de venir
autour de la table de négociation fort
de leur contrat elle fait le récit d'une
impuissance de l'État écouter là au
Sénat en 2020 elles ont eu le beurre et
l'argent du beurre de elles ont fait
croire parce que on était insuffisamment
énergique en face que il y avait une
obligation d'augmentation permanente des
tarifs ils avaient réussi quand même à
faire croire à tous leurs interlocuteurs
du côté de l'État ah bah oui mais
l'augmentation c'est tous les ans or
c'est pas vrai quand on regarde et même
dans le contrat et d'ailleurs la Cour
des comptes le dit clairement et la
Commission européenne le disent mais non
soit ça augmente soit ça baisse alors à
l'époque un gouvernement avait négocié
des rallongements des concessions en
échange de travaux pour 3,2 milliards
d'euros à un moment donné vous dites
qu'il faut plus jamais refaire ça on
vous a entendu le dire récemment mais on
retiendra cette leçon quand même de Sega
Royal lâché en 2020 il faut qu'on arrête
d'être naïf qu'on est aussi l'esprit
business au profit de l'État est-ce que
vous faites le même constat d'une
impuissance de l'État dans ce dossier
bien sûr moi j'étais surpris dans
l'audition de Ségolène Royal qu'elles
disent qu'elle avait signé le protocole
de 2015 dont on a déjà parlé un petit
peu sans connaître son contenu donc moi
ça m'a quand même un peu surpris si vous
aviez pris l'extrême et mais en
l'occurrence le protocole de 2015
effectivement on a négocié aussi en
position de faiblesse parce que elle
avait pris une initiative personnelle
qui était à mon avis même pas partagée
au niveau gouvernemental avait annoncé
le gel des tarifs de 2015 et à partir de
là effectivement on était en position de
faiblesse vis-à-vis des sociétés
d'autoroute et du coup le protocole 2015
a été négocié à toute vitesse encore une
fois toute vitesse avec finalement trois
ans de prolongation contre 4 milliards
de travaux mais en réalité quand on fait
le calcul on s'aperçoit que les autres
les sociétés d'autoroute ils gagnent en
plus souvent les travaux ils sont
décalés dans le temps donc et ça on
réajuste pas les choses donc en fait les
4 milliards ils sont pas dépensés au
moment où c'était prévu mais un petit
peu plus tard un peu plus décalé donc
tout ça donc c'est des choses où
effectivement la puissance publique
manque remonter je pense et le
gouvernement la plupart du temps aussi
alors peut-être qu'il a d'autres choses
à gérer bien entendu mais c'est un sujet
majeur parce que c'est un sujet majeur
parce que d'abord il y a de l'argent
public moi je crois pas à la gratuité on
pourrait peut-être en discuter
parce que pour les gens effectivement la
nationalisation ça peut vous la dire
gratuitement mais c'est une erreur
monumentale parce que d'abord il y a
rien de gratuit si c'est pas l'usager
qui qui paye c'est le contribuable et
ensuite en Espagne par exemple ils ont
fait ça mais ça veut dire que tous les
touristes qui vont en Espagne en fait
ils roulent sur le dos du contribuable
espagnol bon c'est gentil mais
c'est comme la France
d'autoroutes et pas beaucoup de
véhicules qui sont pas des véhicules
français bon ben c'est bien qu'il
contribue aussi à l'entretien de nos
voix nos routes nationales et que on
puisse aussi utiliser cet argent là pour
améliorer nos infrastructures non
seulement routière mais aussi
ferroviaire et c'est vrai que ça sera
intéressant qu'on puisse utiliser il
s'agit il s'agit pas de dire on va faire
des cadeaux automobilistes mais si
électoralement ça serait sympathique
mais en réalité on n'est pas du tout
dans cette époque là vous voyez pas là
pour favoriser la voiture mais on est là
pour utiliser cet argent pour faire des
choses qui soient et si pour l'intérêt
général est-ce qu'il faut en passer par
une Renault nationalisation même si j'ai
bien entendu l'argument Dominique de
Villepin c'est vrai que ça appartient
toujours à l'état mais enfin les
concessions sont tellement longues que
bref on peut on peut se poser la
question regardez cette tribune d'une
trentaine de sénateurs et députés
socialiste qui a été publié je crois que
c'était samedi dans le monde il milite
pour la création d'un établissement
public pour gérer l'ensemble du réseau
routier national y compris les
autoroutes lorsque leur contrats seront
échus voilà ce que ce qui écrivent ces
sénateurs et député socialiste Olivier
vabot est-ce que est-ce que l'État
ferait forcément mieux que les sociétés
privées c'est une question centrale
science essentielle d'autant plus que
malheureusement il y a plein
d'illustrations qui comptent que parfois
l'État n'est pas tout à fait aussi
efficace que que les acteurs privés
d'autant plus que c'est un métier de
professionnel c'est technique il y a
beaucoup de modernisation il y a des des
évolutions technologiques très très
fortes beaucoup de choses qui vont être
demandés aux autoroutes si vous comparez
en revanche est-ce que on sait vraiment
le faire aussi bien ça veut dire que on
va devoir embaucher plein de gens
commencer à le faire c'est pas par
hasard si même dans l'eau très souvent
c'est les concessions c'est parce qu'on
préfère donner à des entreprises privées
dont c'est le métier et le savoir-faire
la cute la question derrière c'est
effectivement de contrôler le tarif le
fonctionnement le retour sur
investissement et donc bien écrire les
contrats cette question de la
renationalisation le gouvernement a
répondu en l'occurrence le ministre de
la transition écologique Christophe
mechut c'était au Sénat il répondait à
une question de Marie-Noëlle Lienemann à
la question très précise est-ce que le
gouvernement est prêt à travailler à la
perspective de la radio nationalisation
des autoroutes ma réponse est la même
que celle que la Haute Assemblée a faite
à la proposition de loi qui a été porté
par votre groupe c'est non
la Russie nationalisation
la renationalisation c'est 50 milliards
d'euros ces 50 milliards d'euros nous
avons la conviction que nous devons les
utiliser au service non pas de la route
mais de la décarbonation des transports
des reports fluviaux et en particulier
des investissements dans le ferroviaire
c'est vrai Martine orange que il y a des
investissements quand même importants à
faire aujourd'hui sur les autoroutes
notamment pour répondre à
l'électrification qui est enquête en
cours il y a des investissements
importants mais je voudrais revenir déjà
sur ce que me disait monsieur Babou
parce que on a su faire
on a su construire des très belles
autoroutes c'est la puissance publique
qui les a construites les autoroutes et
sous contrôle de la DDE sur le contrôle
du ministère des Transports et on savait
parfait on avait parfaitement une
expertise mais les moyens de faire les
choses je ne vois pas
on pourrait faire la transition
écologique de la même façon par exemple
il faut il faut quand même non il faut
il faut il faut regarder la transition
écologique va demander énormément de
capitaux des masses de capitaux qui sont
qui sont qui sont qui parlent de
l'équipement des autoroutes je parle pas
en général je parle de l'écran des
autoroute
oui mais
c'est pas c'est à mon avis c'est pas
c'est pas les les dépenses les plus les
plus urgentes la dépenser plus urgentes
c'est quand même le l'entretien elle
maintient de ferroviaire parce que
pendant qu'on a nationalisé pendant
qu'on a reçu
recéder les concessions autoroutières en
privé on s'est privé d'autant d'argent
pour le ferroviaire on a détruit 15000
km de réseau ferroviaire faute de
pouvoir les entretenir et cet argent des
péages il servait aussi
dans un instant évidemment mais Olivier
Babeau je reste je suis un peu déçu sur
ces investissements qu'est-ce que ça
représente aujourd'hui pour les sociétés
d'autoroute de de passer à l'é
et compétences et c'est vrai que l'État
si vous me donnez à un service ou une
infrastructure qui est bien gérée par
l'État moi je suis preneur faut que vous
me donniez l'exemple tout de suite là
moi je pense que l'État est la plupart
du temps pas bon gestionnaire et
s'adresser à des sociétés qui ont la
compétence et de savoir-faire je pense
que c'est le meilleur moyen d'optimiser
le retour le retour pour le public sauf
qu'il faut avoir des bons contrats et un
bon suivi et aujourd'hui on a un
meilleur suivi pas encore optimal mais
on n'a pas de bon contrat donc c'est ça
qui c'est ça qui cloche alors après les
investissements vous posez la question
sur les investissements alors les
sociétés d'autoroute vous les
interpeller aujourd'hui et elles vont
vous dire ah ben c'est 60 milliards
voilà moi j'ai déjà entendu ce chiffre
on nous dit c'est 60 milliards vous
rendez compte c'est énorme bon il
faudrait expertiser ce chiffre là c'est
leur chiffrage à eux c'est pas d'un coup
déjà c'est pas d'un coup ça vient pas
comme ça d'un seul coup et ce qu'il faut
il faut faire très attention de toute
façon aujourd'hui à ces contrat parce
que effectivement si on veut récupérer
les autoroutes en bon état à la fin des
contrats il faut que les sociétés
continuent à dire et moi dans ce que
j'ai vu dans leur prévision c'est qu'il
y avait plutôt une baisse des
investissements sur les dernières années
du contrat ce qui veut dire que en fait
l'entretien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on peut se dire enfin en fin
de contrat finalement on va avoir un
truc et puis après on peut toujours
entamer un contentieux et vous diront
bah nous on a les insolites vous pouvez
y aller donc c'est pour ça que moi je
pense que s'il faut entamer un
contentieux il faut mieux l'entamer dès
aujourd'hui faut pas attendre la fin des
contrats pour entamer un contentieux et
on a des sociétés qui maîtrisent bien
leur sujet donc il y a pas de raison de
ne pas continuer avec elle à condition
qu'on soit d'accord sur les conditions
avec desquels on continue et la question
de l'autorité de régulation évidemment
vous voulez intervenir je me disais que
il y a quand même besoin vous le dites
sur la transition écologique les
autoroutes si c'était à l'état il
commencerait à penser partage
covoiturage il y a des fils qui sont
réservés pour ça on commence à avoir sur
les autres comment ils pensent aussi
hein
déjà en place parfois et qui qui vont
peut-être se débloquer tout à fait et
puis vous avez dit l'électrique on peut
penser des stations même à hydrog ène
des choses comme ça donc quand vous
regardez sur l'énergie ce qu'on anticipe
au niveau de l'État sur l'électricité
vous sentez qu'ils aient anticipent
beaucoup là pour 2030 et 2035 moi je pas
du tout
creuse un sujet avec l'État il y a
aucune anticipation
mais il y a des besoins il y a une sur
rentabilité et c'est pas le seul endroit
où il y a ces aspects là c'est à dire
beaucoup de besoins et notamment en
termes d'investissement dans la
transition écologique et beaucoup de
super profits comme on en a parlé ou en
tout cas de sur rentabilité ou en tout
cas de gains exceptionnel est-ce qu'il y
a pas quelque chose à faire là en terme
d'État d'une manière un petit peu plus
globale parce que de toute façon on sait
que la transition écologique il va
falloir la financer quelque part et ça
va pas être l'état seulement qui va
pouvoir la financer mais tiens je
reviens sur la la question de
l'augmentation là du mois de février
elle était automatique on peut l'état
malheureusement
prévu dans les contrats
ceci étant dit elle est déconnectée elle
est déconnectée de l'évolution des
charges des sociétés d'autoroute c'est
ça qui va pas parce que qu'on compense
l'augmentation de leur charge on se
dirait bah oui ok on comporte mais là on
fait beaucoup plus que compenser ça veut
dire qu'on leur donne 300 millions
d'euros par an de plus de profits dont
vous parliez de 4 milliards tout à
l'heure mais il y a 300 millions en plus
du fait de cette augmentation et jusqu'à
la fin des contrats donc à un moment
donné c'est pas normal qu'on laisse les
choses en l'état on l'a et alors après
ils vous disent on fait quelques petits
gestes on fait 20 millions de gestes
attendez il faut les remercier pour 20
millions et de l'autre côté ils ont
poche 300 merci beaucoup et évidemment
je termine en disant qu'on a proposé aux
sociétés autoroutes de participer à ce
débat et que elles n'ont pas souhaité le
faire je vous dis à demain pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public et puis
notez que le prochain invité politique
sur notre antenne dans la matinale rien
de bonsigny reçoit Laurent Marc en génie
le président du groupe horizon à
l'Assemblée belle soirée à toutes et à
tous